[Applause]
changing what the new science of
psychedelics teaches us about
consciousness dying addiction depression
and transcendence Michael Pollan Michael
[Applause]
perfect guest for this discussion if
you're looking to convince someone to do
more drugs you have come to the right
we're talking about drugs and your book
is about drug people know you as a food
guide now what why did change did you
just pick the wrong mushroom I thought
there were chanterelles I was putting in
that omelet you have to be there you
have to be careful right you do Oh piggy
mushrooms yes I remember you don't get
once they grow in cow [ __ ] they do
that's right those are the safer wants
to pick there are other ones that you
can really kill yourself a few don't
don't do it yourself but no I've always
been interested in our engagement with
the natural world how nature changes us
the things we take into our bodies how
it affects our health and so for me it
seems more continuous part of the
spectrum and one of the really
interesting things all of us use plants
for and fun guys to change consciousness
right whether it's coffee fungi use
mushrooms right right or chocolate I
mean and this is a universal human
desire that I've always been curious
well I wouldn't say chocolate changes
our consciousness it doesn't subtle ways
oh yeah you know it's got well it has it
has caffeine in it and it has another
thing that kind of gives you a little
lift you know parts legal now right yeah
no so but psychedelics obviously are a
much more radical form of conscious how
about LSD LSD and psilocybin DMT
ayahuasca see I see I feel like they're
so different I never did Hiawatha
but I did I did
I've certainly done well I don't know if
I did acid you know what I did something
that somebody sold to me and suck us out
yeah that's the problem that is that is
they you know if you're a prohibition
you can't regulate yeah Timothy Leary
once said to me before of course before
he died
not
he's attitude he still speak to him
again there he said he said there really
hasn't been acid since owlsley the
original maker yeah at a certain point
the mob moved in on on acid in the
Haight and mob the mob yeah they were
for hippies selling acid in San
Francisco in 1967 and one was killed
horribly hung up from a tree a second
was killed the other two realized bad
business right hey left the mob got in
and the acid was never the same right I
know I don't think it was asset because
they can tell you it's anything right
but it was something I mean it was a it
wasn't good as good as it should have
been but but you're saying real acid
which they experimented with in the 30s
and 40s really helps a lot of people
with stuff like PTSD right and anxiety
and alcoholism alcoholism yeah how does
it do it so so what I was surprised to
learn
I thought psychedelics began in the 60s
but there was a very rich history
research in the 50s late 40s using LSD
psilocybin the ingredient magic
mushrooms to help people deal with
serious problems we don't know exactly
how it works but it seems to lead when
it works there is a profound experience
of ego dissolution sometimes called a
mystical experience people's sense of
their ego or self dissolves temporarily
and when this happens you're freed of
various patterns of thought the brain
kind of reboot and when and this single
experience and it's important to
understand that the way these drugs are
being used in therapeutic settings very
different than the way you use them or I
don't know about you guys
[Laughter]
[Applause]
by the way private we put something in
your water I'm gonna make the second
half of the show a little bloody water
yeah it's a very different thing
it's a guided experience you're with a
therapist the whole time they prepare
you well that's air for one well talk
about a buzzkill for a trip you're with
a therapist the whole time thanks dad no
thanks if you get into trouble
basically they encourage you to
surrender cuz where I feel your ego
dissolving it can be really scary it's a
death right and so they tell you to go
with it relax your mind and float
downstream and John Lennon advised and
and then during the experience which you
you you're lying down you're wearing eye
shades so it's a very internal voyage
you're listening to music on headphones
and they're there with you the whole
time in case you get nervous or freaked
out in some way and then afterwards you
come back the next day and they help you
integrate the experience figure out what
it means and apply it to your lives
people come up with these radical new
perspectives on their own lives that
allows them to change yo it happened to
you yeah oh yeah what's change what was
the perspective how are you different
before how is life actually different
very hard to articulate but I did have
on a high dose psilocybin trip guided I
had an experience of complete ego
dissolution I looked out and I saw
myself painted over the landscape I was
just like butter or paint out there but
I wasn't troubled by this at all
there was another eye that suddenly
manifest that was very kind of fine with
whatever happened and it made me realize
for the first time that I'm not
identical to my ego that there's another
ground on which you can stand and that
becomes that turns out to be a very
powerful idea most of us are slaves of
our egos I didn't had that experience
with mushrooms and I did much if you
take enough I oh I definitely
I've taken a mushrooms are done many
times so it's a laughing drug to me
right you don't find yourself just
laughing uncontrollably no it's about
context because I mean again really I
was having this inner trip I wasn't like
the senses were not coming in I was dark
and I'm just on the floor yeah just
really no like literally on the floor
and like everything's funny because like
everything that is normal in your life
when you think of is hysterically as it
doesn't make sense like most drugs make
me horny but but like not not mushroom
Ann its sex seems like why would I do
that why would I make my penis get
bigger and put it inside of a person
really that's what makes me it makes me
deconstruct everything like that's one
of the new perspectives I was talking
about your sex edition addiction has
been cured it's not an addiction don't
need no cure it alright my last thing
ever is micro dosing a lot of people
thinking about micro dose which is a
little bit about Les Deux and they take
it during the day I mean there's no work
yeah they're not the lizard king they're
just out doing their normal thing what
do you know about that is that something
you recommend so no we don't know thanks
for coming
there's a lot of anecdotal evidence that
it helps people makes them more creative
makes them less depressed but I looked
into it there's no research at all we've
never done a study at a controlled study
it's good it's getting underway in the
next year or two so we may learn more it
strikes me as a funny thing that we've
taken this drug that is so
transformative and disruptive and we've
turned it into with micro dosing just
another productivity drug make you a
better cog in the machine right like
coffee it's like what would calculations
do with psychedelics micro dose that's
why they love coffee yes so work and
tobacco
[Applause]